some people claimed it was a miracle a
humpback whale was spotted in Montreal's
St Lawrence River this young whale had
swam almost 500 km Upstream in fresh
water to visit the city it was first
spotted May 30th 2020 just several days
after the city of Montreal reopened
after being hit by a soul crushing first
wave of covid-19 infections and
lockdowns humpback whales had never been
seen before in Montreal many viewed the
whale as a sign of Hope in the middle of
an awful pandemic but was this really a
covid miracle or was this just a tragedy
waiting to
unfold 113 questions about
Evolution with John
Perry evolutionary question number 32
can Wales survive in freshwater
Montreal's humpback whale and the Amazon
River dolphin recently I posted a
YouTube short on the stated clearly
Channel about the Amazon River dolphin
this is a genus of freshwater Dolphins
living in South America which you're
almost guaranteed to meet if you join me
on this Summer's Evolution tour in the
Amazon jungle in that stated clearly
short I made the claim that if you were
to take a whale or a dolphin from the
ocean and just drop it off either in a
lake or a river I claimed that it would
die a lot of people pushed back on that
and for Fairly good reason right Dolph
and whales are not fish they don't have
gills if they were fish that had to
breathe water with their gills it would
make sense that tossing a saltwater
species into a river might kill it you'd
expect that gills need to be specially
adapted either for salt water or for
fresh water but again dolphins and other
whales don't have gills they are mammals
they breathe air with lungs shouldn't
any saltwater mammal assuming it can
find enough food be able to survive just
fine in fresh water sadly for the people
of Montreal and by the way I happened to
be living in Montreal at that time the
answer is no Marine whales and Marine
Dolphins if you put them in freshwat
they actually do just die several days
after it was first spotted in the St
Lawrence River it was found floating
belly up like a goldfish this was just
like G it was devastating news on top of
everything else all the other crap that
we were dealing with with Co now we had
this we thought it was exciting ooh
there's a whale now it's dead the exact
cause of death was never completely
confirmed the whale had not starved to
death so researchers first assumed it
was hit by a boat but a closer look
revealed a more likely explanation
ulcerative dermatitis better known as
freshwater skin disease there are
certain types of marine mammals that do
just fine in freshwater and in saltwater
Florida's manatees are totally happy
either way but whale in Dolphin skin
absorbs the water they swim in Marine
whales and dolphins have skin adapted to
cope with dense saltwater exclusively if
you take a saltwater dolphin and toss it
in a river over the course of several
days to weeks the less dense fresh water
gradually invades the Dolphins collagen
fibers and skin cells if the animal
can't find salt water again soon the
skin will inflate so much that it
Bubbles and bursts like a third degree
burn death by infection soon follows
scientists understand how this process
works especially well for bottle-nosed
dolphins because the US Navy uses them
as soldiers well sort of as soldiers
they're mostly used to find things that
the Navy lost in the water cell phones
car keys apocalyptic nuclear warheads
sometimes these Soldier dolphins are
even sent on freshwater missions during
such missions Navy scientists have found
that noticeable skin lesions start to
develop around 12 days of freshwater
exposure this begins with a yellow of
the skin the general blood chemistry of
a dolphin goes way out of whack
sometimes in just 24 hours of freshwater
exposure they really do not handle it
well early footage of the Montreal
humpback seems to show noticeable
yellowing of the skin a sure sign that
trouble was brewing so if freshwater
kills whales and dolphins how then are
their entire species of freshwater
Dolphins how does that evolve well the
the transition from Salt to fresh water
is a slow evolutionary process multiple
mutations are needed to fully cope with
fresh water complex adaptations can't
just poof into existence in a single
step this means they needed a
transitional environment to accommodate
their evolution to fresh water behold
the mouth of the Amazon River a tropical
Estuary the mouth of a river an estuary
is a nutrient rich and in this case a
species Rich mixing area filled with
bracket ish water brackish means part
salty part fresh details about the
evolution to fresh water for the large
Amazon River dolphin those details are
mostly lost to history when I say large
river dolphins I'm talking about what
locals call the boto botos are the ones
that we see on the evolution tour
they're the ones that live in Ecuador
young botos are gray older botos
especially males they rub their pigment
off as they age and they end up turning
pink in color there is a saltwater
version of the boto dolphin that still
lives in the ocean off the coast of
Southern Brazil but genetic testing
suggests the freshwater and saltwater
groups split from each other over 11
million years ago and just to put that
in perspective the human chimp split was
something like six 5 to 7 million years
ago so this happened a long time ago the
saltwater boto and freshwater boto split
that said there is a separate type of
dolphin the little bottle-nosed satalia
that are undergoing this transition
right now this group of dolphins is
currently split into two populations
that are almost indistinguishable by
Anatomy alone but genetic testing shows
they rarely interbreed crosses are so
rare in fact that biologists have
decided to call them two different
species one group likes saltwater and
the other group likes freshwater locals
call The Saltwater version costos
because they're Coastal they live at the
mouth of the river and sometimes they're
found out at Sea and those that belong
to the freshwater population are known
as tushi The Saltwater group can Venture
pretty far Upstream into freshwat when
hunting is better there but it can't
stay forever researchers have found that
it's only partly adapted to fresh water
for example it lacks a key mutation in
its mitochondrial DNA that we know helps
convert food into energy in low salt
environments from the Dolphins
perspective it likely feels sluggish if
it stays in fresh water too long and
when it goes back to salt salt water it
feels recharged re-energized and so they
end up just staying in salt water more
often one of the really cool things
about estuaries is that saltwater is
heavier than fresh water meaning that
when the river meets the sea fresh water
actually floats on top of the salt water
for a surprisingly long time between the
two layers is a transition line called
the hline what this means is that if
you're a saltwater dolphin exploring the
mouth of a river near the surface of the
water you get to hunt freshwater fish
you get to learn about their behavior
what they taste like but then if you
need a little bit of salt all you have
to do is dive down here's a little bit
of footage that I took at a tide pool in
Oregon on the top here we see fresh
water coming in from a river a little
stream and it's dumping into a tide pool
when I put my hand in you can see about
5 in down there is the saltwater
freshwater line the salt content of the
water is so different that it refracts
light differently and you can see as I
move my hand through that line
through the
hline you can see the hline just with
the naked eye it's really cool
transition lines exist like this in
Estuary that allows saltwater fish to
live underneath the freshwater and
freshwater fish to live above the
saltwater Dolphins playing in this
region get to hunt both types of animals
this really helps in The evolutionary
transition from saltwater to freshwat
the freshwater population of satalia
again they're locally called tushi they
have many atap for fresh water including
the mutations in its mitochondrial DNA
that optimizes it for energy production
in low salt while this group will
sometimes visit the Estuary they're not
reported to every Explorer in the open
oceans it seems like they've lost their
tolerance for the level of salt that
exists in the ocean okay so that was
kind of a lot let me just recap this and
put it into it you know more compact uh
explanation here the Amazon River is
loaded with fish that Marine Dolphins
would love to sink their teeth into but
it hurts a dolphin to stay in fresh
water too long that said the Estuary has
the best of both worlds there are fish
to eat from the ocean and from the river
the lower layer of water has plenty of
salt whenever the dolphin needs a
soothing recharge any individual with a
mutation that happens to let it stay in
fresh water longer than its Rivals well
it gets an evolutionary Edge it can
travel further Upstream with fewer
competitors where it's able to freely
catch more food and is likely going to
give rise to more offspring this means
natural selection can promote any
mutation that even enables just a little
bit more freshwater tolerance as
mutations for freshwat accumulate over
many generations they can eventually
survive fulltime in freshwater evidence
for evolution in the waters of the
Amazon River before I go Nancy the
entomologist who runs the evolution tour
she made a little promo video that I
think is pretty cool I want to show that
to you here but before I do that I just
want to point out how fun it is to visit
the Amazon jungle with a real
entomologist a scientist who studies
bugs because she studies bugs she knows
exactly which ones you can pick up
safely and which ones you cannot pick up
safely there's a lot of things in the
Amazon jungle that are dangerous also
she teaches you how to handle the
insects so that you don't hurt them if
you're interested you should definitely
sign up for the newsletter on Evo tour.
info because tickets go on sale soon and
there are only 15 slots without further
Ado here is ny's epic promo
[Music]
video
hello people of the internet John Perry
here in today's video I just found this
pile of crazy stuff that washed up on
the
beach hello bug friends my name is Nancy
I an enologist that's my Master's Degree
have hazly taped to my wall back there
and I conduct personalized TS of Ecuador
focused on insects ecology local culture
and
[Music]
[Applause]
conservation
[Music]
if all you eat is leaves you're probably
picky I like that there's a stick for
reference